making America great again Donald
Trump's candidacy is a cancer on
conservatism when we elect Donald Trump
the 45th President of the United States
together we will make America great
again but I will be voting for Ted Cruz
only with Donald Trump and Mike Pence do
we have a chance at a better way Miami a
person can't do the job because of their
race is sort of like the textbook
definition of a racist comment this is
not conservatism we have a man who wants
to lead us we are not elected an
entertainer in chief vote for Donald
Trump first safer America if you do a
ban on all Muslims I have no question
that you violate the First Amendment and
you start radicalizing a lot more than
if you did it it's time to come together
and fight for a new direction for
America be a party that nominates
someone who refuses to condemn white
supremacist and the klu klux klan we
want a leader who is not afraid to take
on the mess in Washington the special
interest of Washington what you yourself
just said you were part of using the
system you can't take America into
bankruptcy I want to congratulate Donald
Trump on winning the nomination Donald
is a bully a barking carnival carnival
barker a pathological liar a con artist
this con artist on the issue of con
artists that I won't stop saying this
guy is a con artist the man is utterly a
way a toxic mix of demagoguery and
mean-spiritedness and nonsense but he
combines it with being a narcissist
unity is everything